all right beef burrito
beef burrito i mean obvious hulk hogan
tribute is obvious so why go with this
lame name i'm not even saying you have
to go full wordplay like bulk blogon
but beef burrito also dolls with teeth
tag up
check up jeez how much room do these two
need this bedroom is huge
oh you want us to put the hurt on you i
think he wants me to put the hurt on him
i think he wants you to put the hurt on
him you think he wants me to put the
hurt on him ah
so it's gonna be that kind of show is it
got it so i guess we'll just add a few
this goes on for some time since to
cover the repeating things over and over
shenanigans on and on and anagens
how would any of those items pop out of
the trash can when rigby takes up the
entire circumference
did you see how awesome it was when i
hit the trampoline if by awesome you
mean
impossible that the events conspired the
way that they were shown then yeah it
was totally tubular
but it wasn't as awesome as when you
punch that hole in the wall
[Laughter]
i'm not sure which one is beavis and
which one is butthead yet but i'm sure
i'll figure it out by the end of the
episode
dude we're 23 years old we shouldn't be
busting holes in walls you didn't seem
to care too much about holes in walls
when you tacked up that hair metal
poster
hamboning what this plot point does not
refer to them searching for and finding
a don draper sex tape
ham boney will save your life someday
it'll be all like what you trying to mug
me
look i'm trying very hard not to get
caught up in this ridiculousness but
i've only got so much strength
don't worry it won't happen again we
just need to ask him for a raise and
just explain all that no no
no that's not gonna work what are you 65
no because then mordecai would be legal
retiring agent not need a raise and bone
on that little nugget rigby i know what
to do maybe use your chester drawer so
you don't have a grime infested pile of
clothing on the floor
taking a whiz also i get the zipper on a
wizard gown thing is probably a joke but
if the show had bothered to do any
research they would know that wizards
are notoriously anti-zipper anyway and
the whole reason they even wear the
gowns in the first place is because of
the mutilated wand incident of 763
also also stealing
[Applause]
yes there is reverb and such but there
are clearly two extra notes played on
this thing
after discount rocket stops playing and
yes i know this is a magical keyboard or
whatever but i've got my limits
this is the answer to all our problems
which it actually is but there's no way
mordecai could know that and if he's
willing to go with keyboard tactics then
hand boning is all of a sudden not
sounding so stupid
also this is a pretty lame magic
keyboard not only are the keys different
sizes
it starts on an a and ends on an f and
doesn't even span two octaves even the
smallest keyboards usually start on a
low c have a middle c and end on a high
c
have you named her yet actually i
thought you could do the honors
i've always wanted to date a girl named
the power
gendering your objects you want to own
your woman keyboard mordecai you want to
date her and make her do whatever you
say you sick cluck
do ya huh i may need a break from
twitter setting aside that the keyboard
just magically branded itself
what the hell scape section of the
keyboard is this there are literally two
black sharp flat keys over the course of
seven
white keys where are the black keys
representation matters
birds with teeth is that the sound of
music i hear
not sure considering you have no ears
pops dude i think that just worked
i believe you mean this works but i'll
allow it also i think i need a larger
sample size than old guy who keeps
opened butterscotch suckers in his
wallet but we've only got six minutes
left in this episode so
sure you know you guys have been working
harder discount tom servo has garden
tools in his arms here but they
completely disappear after this they're
not in the front of the golf cart not in
the back of the golf cart
not on the ground benson's a legit
warlock y'all apparently regular show
went to the scooby-doo school of
gravitying things
this cd says 80s metal when it should
say 80s metal the apostrophe stands for
the 19.
of course it could be that it's metal
that belongs to the 80s but then
shouldn't the apostrophe be after the s
because there were so many years in the
80s unless it's music from just 1980 but
even so shouldn't it still have the
apostrophe at the front as well it could
be 80s metal or 80s metal or 80s metal
but my point is it should never be 80s
metal
you guys shouldn't be doing what you
just did skips
while we synchronize our watches reverse
psychology
also i'm more curious how they keep
synchronizing these random songs they're
putting together in the spur of the
moment and now all this talk of crotches
has me wondering about benson's
um dispenser did it really have to be
located here
is this intentional is it functional
does that mean his head is full of
benson seed look it's not my fault the
show decided to be vague about genitalia
personification
oh sure on earth you float but on the
moon somehow earth gravity is all in
effect and there's plenty of oxygen to
breathe
beginning to think the creators of this
show don't even care about how the real
world works
a bunch of baby ducks send them to the
moon soda machine that doesn't work but
since rigby just said he couldn't get
skips back from the moon because he
couldn't see him how is he able to send
these things that he also can't see
to the moon skips doesn't defeat this
monster by sticking a bone in its mouth
and then dropping a door on its head
hambone will save your life someday this
book ending is actually clever and funny
and i might have taken a sin away but
then you had to go and basically play
the entire scene as if i needed
reminding of a callback that took place
less than 10 minutes ago you drill bit
you might think i'm going to rattle off
another this works and while it's true
that this
indeed does work i'm more concerned with
why take us to the moon
took them and the cart to the moon but
take us home
took them home and left the cart i get
taking away the keyboard from rigby and
mordecai but
why would skips break it at the very
least sell it to the highest bidder
we have poster we have no poster
you're threatening to punch me so hard
i'm gonna fly to the moon
sometimes we get bored with nitpicking
movies to death yo chris
answer your damn phone i have something
to say to you about this pete's dragon
bull
you made me watch stop screening my
calls there's so much other zen in the
world
so a few years ago we decided to point
the old scene counter at those
delightful nuggets of pop artistry
music videos [ __ ] off what what that's
right for all of your pop star mockery
needs we have
music video sins the format is just what
you get in cinemasins but
on this channel you get to see the moral
sins of accomplished musicians like jake
paul ariana grande miley cyrus dj khaled
and cardi b
and while you're there scroll through
our back catalog for choice bits from
taylor swift jason derulo
meghan trainor camila cabello and much
more subscribe today for more laughs
than you can handle check out music
video sins
now that's what i want you to do
but it wasn't as awesome as when you
punch that hole in the wall
[Music]
look just come check it out i'm a cat
now check me out
is that the sound of music i hear it's
singing
yes i realize it's singing but who is
singing
at least we can test it out on him and
he won't get mad at us if it doesn't
work
that doesn't make sense
brother